I am dating someone but we're not
exclusive so I've been going on dates
with other people and have been honest
about it but now they're getting upset
with me and feeling as if I'm cheating
on them am I in the wrong look you're
not in the wrong but I'm of the opinion
that if you really like someone it's
almost worth giving that a moment and
filling your life with other things so
that you're not relying on a text from
that person to make you feel good so go
out with your friends fulfill your
passions your hobbies you'll lose
yourself in your purpose your work so
that you still pace yourself give that a
minute to actually see if it feels like
it's promising because if you if you
already have that sense it doesn't mean
you're right it might not be promising
the most you'll lose is a couple of
weeks in seeing how that person is
showing up in your life and how they're
investing and if you don't like the way
they're showing up you can always point
out to them that hey I like you I was
kind of excited you know where this was
going but I didn't hear from you so I'm
not sure whether to put my energy
elsewhere